تواترت الادانات والاقليميه والدوليه
للانقلاب العسكري في النيجر الذي حذر
قادته من اي تدخل خارجي في البلاد ان كان
ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه
مسارات ما الاسباب التي تقف وراء الرفض
الغربي الصارم للانقلاب في النيجر وكيف
يمكن ان تتطور الاوضاع في النيجر على ضوء
تصاعد الرفض الدولي للانقلاب وما العوامل
التي ستحكم خطوات كل الاطراف تجاه ما يجري
في النيجر
بالنسبه لفرنسا ويتحل الاوروبي الولايات
المتحده هناك اسباب قبل كل شيء سياسي
وامنيه قويه جدا ضربت ما بين النيجر وهذه
الاطراف الثلاث بالنسبه للاتحاد الافريقي
لان هناك بوند داخل الاتحاد الافريقي يمنع
الاتحاد من الاعتراف باي نظام سياسي ياتي
اثراء انقلاب الفرنسيين هم
لديهم تقريبا لواء من المظاليين هناك
وهناك بعض المشاكل عن مجموعه 1500 جندي
يمكن ان يكون العون الافريقي على هذا هذه
القوه الفرنسيه والقوه الخاصه الامريكيه
الموجوده في اكاديس ان الولايات المتحده
وخاصه فرنسا
ذهبت بعيدا في تعاونيها الامني لمحاربه
كما تقول التنظيمات الارهابيه وكذلك
لاسباب اقتصاديه معروفه هناك الخوف لدى
واشنطن ولدها باريس بان في النهايه الذهاب
بعيدا في العقوبات ضد النظام الجديد في
النيجر سيفتح الباب في النهايه لروسيا او
كذلك لربما لدوله اخرى يمكن ان يتسلم
الجيش النيجيري مددا من روسيا عبر باماكو
وعبر الحليف الليبي
لانه بينها حدود ليبيا مشتركه مع النيجر
خوف الكبير بان فرنسا في النهايه ستفقد
حتى الدول الاخرى لان ستفقد مصداقيتها في
المنطقه وتقول الانظمه الافريقيه بان
فرنسا لا يمكن ان يعول عليها للحفاظ على
الدول هي او الانظمه الصديقه لباريس
[موسيقى]
بدات الامور تتضح انه الجيش حسم امره
واجتمع خلف قيادته منذ يومين تقريبا
وبالتالي المواجهه القادمه هي ستكون مع
الجيش باكمله وليس مع مع فيلقين او لواء
على حساب فيلق اولياء وهنا مكمل الداء
يعني اقوى نقاط الضعف عند الانقلابين هو
عدم استقاله الرئيس بازون سلامه بوعزوم
الشخصيه ووجوده كدرع بشري لدى الانقلابيين
هي تقريبا 90% من اوراق القوه لديهم ان
نجحت عبر عمليه خاطفه بمساعده
من فيلافير اللي موجوده في القصر الرئاسي
فسيخسر الانقلابيون وكل الاوراق انا اعتقد
ان فرنسا ستستمر على المصارين يعني مسار
انتظار خروج بازون باي طريقه رغم ان
الموجبه العسكريه اعتقد فيها مخاطره كبيره
المسار الثاني هو المسار
التفاوض مع العسكر من اجل ضمانات
انقلابيين في النيجر يختلفون عنهم في
بوركينا فاسو وفيما لان هذه مجموعه من
الجنرالات
تجارب لما راينا سيرهم ذاتيه ليسوا ضباطا
واعتقدوا ان مهاجمتهم وتكبيلهم القوه ضدهم
لن يكون لعبه النظام الجديد في النيجر هو
مطالب بتحريك الشارع اذا اذا ظهر الشارع
خرج الشارع يقول بانه في النهايه مع هذه
السلطه الجديده من الصعب على باريس او على
الاتحاد الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
في شعر بانه يبدا في مرحله انتقاليه
بمساعده بمساعده وسوفه او مساعده مجاهد
اخرى وبان الجيش سينصرف عن الحياه الحياه
السياسيه عندما تتشكل حكومه جديده هذه
الضمانات اعتقد ان فرنسا لن ترفض هنالك يد
ممدوده من العسكر لفرنسا تضمن لفرنسا 33%
من اليورانيوم واعتقد ان فرنسا تقول شيئا
في العلم وستقول اشياء اخرى في السر يعني
خيبه الامل الفرنسيه ان الضباط المجموعه
المسلحه هي في النهايه كانت تتعاون بشكل
بشكل منتظم مع الضباط الفرنسيين الموجودين
اشد الدول واشد الجهات حرجا في هذه
اللحظات لانه تغذي مفاعلات النوويه من
ارليت في النيجر وتعتبره اخر الحلفاء بعد
وفاه ادريس ديبي
طردها غير لبق من من مالي واخراجها
المتوقع او غير المفاجئ من بوركينا فاسو
تحتاج الى الى النيجر
كحاضنه لقواتها في الدول الساحل روسيا
مهتمه جدا واعتقد انها بدات اصلا بعض
المفاوضات لانها اذا استطعت ان تصل الى
نيامي فانها وصلت في النهايه الى الساحل
وصلت الى الحزام الاساسي لسواء عندما دول
شمال افريقيا او حتى النفوذ الفرنسي الذي
ابعد من ذلك قوه الموقف الامريكي الذي هو
مع باريس هو كذلك لانها فعلا تخشى من ان
موسكو تجد بابا للدخول في النجم